sponsored by step finance your
go to d5 portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh fans show
super excited to do this podcast because i have
my new studio as you can see i have a new mic
so if i'm coming through nice and clear can you
let me know um so i'm really excited to jump into
all of this now before we kick things off um this
show is sponsored by bitmex um so i want to do a
quick shout out to them so um bitmex is actually
an og crypto derivatives exchange and now has
a spot exchange for you to buy and sell crypto
especially in a bear market you need a name
that you can trust bitmex sets the standard
in reliability performance and transparency and
of course it has proven itself through multiple
cycles stood the test of time and that's really
important with everything that's going on right
now and everything that we're actually going
to talk about on the show um right now bimx is
actually celebrating the start of bitmex spot with
1 million usd in prizes pretty insane so to enter
users just need to trade the crypto equivalent of
250 us dollars users can enter up to um 25 times
to win their share of the um sweet steaks so it's
pretty good one lucky winner will even receive
500 000 usd in bit in bit max um in bitcoin
from bit max so pretty insane stuff there
now um in order to be part of this i've left um a
description and a link for you two bit max in the
description below so definitely go check them out
now this show is also sponsored by our friends at
step finance and joining me today to talk about
all of this the market what is going on whether d5
is over um is george harp the co-founder of step
finance spring george on george welcome to the
show how you doing hi leia it's great to be here
good to be back yeah it's great to speak with you
um last time we spoke you were traveling all over
the world you were sort of escaping the lockdowns
um can we get um a quick update where are you
right now yeah getting arrested or something
oh god hopefully not yeah like so i've been i've
been traveling a bit as well still but i'm trying
to like chill out on that a bit to be honest
i'm kind of sick of it um but uh no like i've
been to asia recently and um went over to vietnam
for a bit it was probably like the only country
that's really sort of opened up in asia so it's
like my first time back in a couple of years um
uh now in turkey and sort of around europe as
well so uh so yeah just sort of doing my thing
and uh yeah you know i'd sort of i think this
for the next 12 months i might sort of not be
traveling as much because it seems like all
of this covered nonsense is kind of ending so
it's actually getting a bit easier and you
don't have to like move every couple of months
yeah well you're in turkey um i remember at one
point turkey had those necessary magical passes
that you needed and those injection passes so
what's it like right now i'm turkey i'm guessing
it's a bit better oh yeah i mean there's none of
that now which is great um so so yeah i mean look
like i was walking down the street the other day
i saw like eight different uh crypto shops that
were just like exchanging it for for cash for all
these different coins um i dare say they're not
regulated they probably don't have licenses which
is great um and yeah they're just there doing
business which is what you want to see so so as
a country it gives like it's a thumbs up from me
uh but uh yeah but turkey's pretty interesting
because um i think the didn't the president of
el salvador go to turkey recently or the or the
head of state from turkey went over to el salvador
um and also the currency is not doing very well
so you know do you think they're likely to would
be the next country to adopt bitcoin any other
crypto what do you think you know what i think
it's probably seeping into society here more than
other countries like there's just random shops on
the street that you can oh you want to repair your
iphone or something cool you can pay the guy in
tether or bitcoin or something um and you don't
really see that everywhere right like and i had
another friend i was talking to as well recently
who was saying very much the same sort of thing
so yeah i think as a society maybe people have
been pushed more towards crypto because the lira
is kind of a nonsense currency that's been blown
up um and maybe that's kind of a catalyst but as
i i think i've mentioned before i think it's about
one third of the country has an exchange account
um and uh that's that's crazy numbers like that
that is really big um so yeah i actually heard
that number when i was talking to one of the
exchange operators here so um yeah it's uh
it's huge that's crazy um i love i love i mean i i
was gonna say i'd love to see it but to be clear i
don't love to see the lyric crashing i don't like
to see any fiat currency crashing unfortunately
um but i love to see the adoption and particularly
in countries that need it um but let's kick things
off um it's been a pretty hectic i'd say week
we've seen crazy liquidations um before we get
into all of that for those that don't know can
you tell us a little bit about step finance
sure so step is a on a it's a portfolio manager
really it's an on-chain data provider for the
solana ecosystem and and we're a place where you
can you know users can manage their portfolio
across all these different uh dapps uh so there's
about 50 different integrations we're monitoring
a lot of on-chain data from all these dexes
yield farms and whatever it might be and uh
yeah we're just sort of that that one place to
go that gives you the overview of everything so
i guess you know with all the market turmoil and
all these different things happening recently
uh we've been sort of sitting at the at the the
bird's eye view of of really what's going on so
yeah yeah you have the information um let's let's
get into this what is your take um you know why
is the market crashing and you know what's
been going on and how long do you think it's
going to last yeah we had a few catalysts
didn't we like it i i guess i don't know
how long it was was it two months ago that
luna was a thing it seems time has warped
it was i know when it was it was but before
i'd gone before i traveled so it was like maybe
april i think it was april may april i'm
going for may early may that's what i'm going
for early something like that right so like a
couple of months ago things really kicked off
uh and we had luna this you know supposed um
alternative blockchain that also had a stable
coin attached to it and ust and the mechanism
of which ust was created was pretty much a ponzi
scheme they did have a lot of crypto backing
it they had like three billion in bitcoin or
whatever then they had 18 billion of this ust coin
issued so it doesn't matter how much collateral
you have like if you have 18 billion owing on
the books and you only have 3 billion backing it
then there's nothing much you can do but you know
that unwinding i think was really the first shock
uh that we saw in the market and then of
course yes there's the macro things going
on you got inflation and the fed and like wars
and all this kind of stuff um so i mean that's
not good and they're not bullish things but um
yeah i think really it started with uh with luna
and then from that that kind of maybe exposed
some of the fragility in the market of you know
now we have like celsius uh more recently
having problems and maybe going under
nobody really knows nobody's like transparent um
and that was like a centralized you know lender
i'm pretty sure they had an app maybe they had
a website as well yeah yeah you could you know
borrow coins and that sort of thing um and then
we had three arrows capital as well who was one
of the very large funds in the ecosystem a lot of
people looked up to them uh and uh they also seem
like they've gone under nobody quite knows again
being very silent not really talking to partners
billions of dollars at stake seems like there was
a lot of leverage in the ecosystem they borrowed
a lot of money didn't pay it back other people
you know are saying where's my money and it's
not there so yeah look i think it's been a crazy
time and all of that um has probably resulted in
a lot of cell pressure on the market right so
you know we in the celsius instance uh in in
that case like i think there was there was one
on-chain contract uh which you could monitor
a lot of people looking at the ether scan uh you
know transaction for that it was like 148 million
uh of ethereum i think was was locked up uh in
that contract and it had a specific liquidation
price so i think we we very nearly escaped
liquidation on that the the price was was very
uh very close but um you know i think that's a
good example of on-chain data right is usually
in a financial market we don't really have an idea
of what people's individual liquidation prices are
what's the real story going on behind the scenes
whereas at least if everything's on chain you can
just like look at the actual blockchain to see
what's going on uh is the money there or not uh
are these loans being paid back or not and that's
been i think a a plus point of the last couple of
weeks is we can at least see what's going on and
people can sort of monitor it in real time which
is pretty cool yeah but i think that not everyone
understands that because you know on chain data
can be super daunting um you know people not you
know a lot of people do own crypto but doesn't
mean they understand the on-chain data side of
things so how can people um essentially start
measuring those on-chain metrics what should they
be looking for um what you know how where do they
go basically to start yeah so i mean fundamentally
these are kind of complex things right you know
when we're talking about collateralizing a loan
in a you know some sort of coin to then borrow
a stable coin to then lend it to someone else for
an interest rate like they're not simple concepts
so i think firstly like definitely reading up on
these things and how they work and the mechanisms
involved that's like step number one right do
your own research it's always step number one um
but after that uh look there's a lot of different
platforms right so uh in the case that i mentioned
before you know that was a specific uh maker dow
vault uh which is a a essentially people lock up
ethereum on the ethereum blockchain and then
they mint a stablecoin against that called die
and you can see these these transactions happening
and and in this case a lot of people are looking
at etherscan for a lot of that information um
in the case of step uh on solana as well uh you
know we you can monitor funding rates across a
lot of the different blockchains and different
pool values and and wallets you can look at
what exposure wallets have to how much they're
borrowing how much uh you know they have in
collateral and what their collateral rates are so
um yeah look i think there's a lot of tools out
there uh nansen another great example uh dune
another great example glass node these are all
sort of giving you these these insights to look
at these contracts but that's only really half
the problem right the other half of the problem
is to understand what on earth all these things
actually mean um so i think you need a bit of both
right having the tools is great but also you sort
of need to know what to look for at the same time
yeah but you you touched on this but i do want
to get more detail on this because liquidations
are um not what we want um you know especially
you don't want to have your funds frozen and you
can't withdraw them so i think that moving forward
people will need to understand the on-chain data
be able to interpret it um and know which places
to stay away from so in terms of you know luna
celsius um 3ac everything that you mentioned what
were people looking at on chain to get the most
accurate information about what's going on yeah
so there's a couple like so the vault was one
you know that was that was apple funding rates
are another one so with luna what we saw was
when it was stuck ust was starting to d peg right
ust was a dollar it was their stable coin and then
it started to go to like 98 cents or 97 cents
or something like that and a lot of people were
watching uh some of the the lunar explorers to
see how much lunar is being burned and redeemed
because how it worked was that essentially you
burned luna to create the stable coin and then
if you wanted to unwind your stable coin then
it created luna so it's kind of like cool it's
great if everyone just burns luna right and then
the price of luna goes up everyone's happy but
when the reverse happens it's kind of a cascade
right so you know a lot of people are looking
at some of these explorers and and we're
seeing like a lot more coins being minted
and that created a lot of inflated supply which
turned up in the futures markets funding rates so
if you went on to some of the futures exchanges
like you know the binance is the world ftx
maybe uh bitmex also has a lunar market i don't
know if they did um but you could see it in the
in the perpetual futures right in one case uh
we could see on step that the funding rate i aka
the price it costs for you to short luna it was
something like 88 000 or 800 000 per year um
so that's pretty pricey right if you're going
to short that currency you're paying a lot of
money to short it um but that really sort of shows
you the sentiment right so given that information
um of what the markets are actually doing
and what people are doing with their money
then maybe you can make the conclusion like
hey this peg is not gonna hold this like 98
cent thing it's probably going to go to zero and
that's exactly what happened uh and uh and we saw
it sort of you know fall quite a bit from there
um we people also monitoring the the movements
as well in in some of the wallets on nansen uh
from the three billion treasury which was meant
to be backing it we saw that that went to binance
and then sort of went into a black hole after that
and the assumption was that all the bitcoin was
sold to try and you know back up this thing and of
course that wasn't good because that was bad for
bitcoin that's a lot of sales and then if bitcoin
goes down everything else comes down as well um
so you know i think that's kind of what creates
these cascades and and uh you know if something
goes down a lot a lot of people get liquidated
that makes it go down more and you get this like
force feedback loop which is uh quite destructive
yeah really destructive um and so
for that reason i want to get into
d5 um i have titled this show is defy over
is defy dead um because you know we often
hear people say when the bear market comes
nothing but bitcoin will survive um you know
i think that is um an exaggeration but what i
think was interesting for me personally this week
um was the disruption on the solana network and
i know obviously step is sort of part of that
ecosystem so and before we get into solana can you
sort of give us some background and an overview of
what actually happened the network was on it was
off the price crashed what happened so it wasn't
it actually the solana network's been great uh
it's been very fast it's the latest update what
the problem was was that there was one individual
application uh called soul land and they were
a lender and they had one uh uh so essentially
you put your uh sole or usdc or you know wrapped
bitcoin or something into their lending protocol
and then you can borrow other coins against it
um so that's all well and good but you can get
liquidated if the value of your collateral falls
and that's exactly what was happening right with
this market turmoil the price of seoul was going
down and this particular whale was something
like you know 70 of of their order book um so
you know very big position and they had a sort of
i guess an emergency internal meeting um they have
a governance token as well so this was all out
in the open so that's i guess another thing to
keep in mind is some of these default protocols
they have these governance tokens right and and
what does that mean well it means that people
get to vote on stuff what do they get to vote on
i mean it's sort of who knows is the first answer
to that um that the second answer is like well
like people can propose their own uh you know
things to vote on and if enough people vote on it
but how it worked out with this particular
scenario was that this well had i think it was 130
million of collateral in this lending protocol and
they were borrowing a hundred million worth their
thereabouts in stable coins and uh and the problem
was if that 130 million went down below 100 then
you know that could cause contagion for the rest
of protocol and everyone loses money kind of thing
um so they had a vote and uh of what to do and one
of the proposals was to take control of the wales
account and to be able to sell that balance right
and how much did you need to to do this vote well
you needed 700k so i think a lot of people quite
rightly brought the point of like hold on i only
need 700k to vote on what to do with 130 million
like that's a pretty crazy situation that's the
first thing secondly like what we're voting to
take someone's money that's also pretty crazy like
why that that's against a lot of ethos right of
decentralization so um they had a second vote and
the second vote annulled the first vote uh and uh
then i think there's been a third vote uh as well
yeah but luckily you know the price of seoul's
gone up so that's no longer a imminent risk um
so yeah like on the first instance like look this
is just one particular uh i guess you call it app
uh on the solana blockchain there's lots of apps
on lots of blockchains um but i guess maybe one
positive to bring out of this is at least it was
all out in the open it wasn't like celsius where
it was like oh i don't know what's happening is
the money going to be there tomorrow who knows
at least we all knew where we stood like we could
see the the position like you could look at the
wallet in step you could go well okay they don't
have that the price goes down too much more like
that money's gonna be poof like disappear yeah
i mean i think having it all out on the open is
really important transparency is obviously key
um particularly um in this space particularly
comes to finance as well but my issue was the fact
that they had the ability to vote to take control
of somebody's money and i think i don't really i
my concerns about that aren't really eased by the
fact that they were able to have another vote
um i for me i'm just like wow like this is bad
um because if that's possible what else is
possible um you know and as somebody who i
know you're would you regard yourself as a freedom
maximalist is that sort of how you say yeah yeah
so somebody who's a freedom maxi a bit like
myself um how how does that sit okay with you
well everyone's able to make their own apps and
everyone's able to make their own configurations
of those apps maybe i make a app where i say that
i'm a communist dictator and and all of the money
has to go to george and yeah nobody has any rights
as long as there's a free market to do that i
great like 100 percent for it and if people want
to invest in that thing fantastic um but uh but
yeah ultimately i think if the first thing was
yes at least it was all transparent the second
thing was that luckily it didn't go through um but
uh yeah it does bring up some questions right yeah
and i think you know the team's probably learned
from that i really like the soul end team i think
they do a great job um but yeah i think maybe this
this vote and this proposal was maybe a misstep
um but uh but to be honest like is it really that
different to a centralized exchange when they can
just lock your account because you didn't do
no like it's no different right so no it's no
different but no i'm with you it's no different
but defy is defy decentralized finance it prides
itself on being sovereign and you know only you
control your assets like sort of reminds me of
the whole issue about metamask we're like oh well
maybe you know it's not that safe which is why
i always say i feel like every bear market
more bitcoin maxies are born well i'd maybe
maybe that's the case i i think certainly bear
markets like expose vulnerabilities and things
that are built up over a bull market and i think
you saw that with 3ac whereby in a bull market wow
with like the best fun in the world we're so rich
got all this money it's pumping woohoo like let's
buy a super yacht um but then as soon as things
don't go their way uh things implode so it kind
of like it exposes maybe some of the underlying
cracks and and that's good for the whole ecosystem
in general we see that every single time there's
always blow ups uh and people get better you know
from the most part uh for that so uh so yeah
i think it's about if people do their research
enough and sort of understand these mechanisms
um then you can at least try and tread the waters
and be able to see you know what's what's a good
idea what's not a good idea and be able to maybe
evaluate that and and you know value the risk
uh involved in some of these different things
so where would you say we're at right now with the
markets um yeah i'm gonna leave the question very
open-ended and broad okay yeah uh well a i don't
know nobody knows i think is the answer all i can
say is look i've been in this thing for over a
decade i've seen this kind of stuff happen many
times before all these different blow ups um peak
fear everyone thinking it's going to zero tomorrow
uh it's not going to zero um and uh there will
be a new blooming of a bull market at some stage
don't know when that'll be um you know don't
know what the catalyst for that will be but
it's always something different you know history
it doesn't repeat itself but it often rhymes so
i think that thing it's it's great isn't it
right and it's true um it's often a little
bit different each time you know there's there's
some similar concepts that we can take from it but
you know it's uh it's a little bit different so
i think we probably have to wait for a lot of
this leverage to to unwind there's still like a
lot of these big funds which built up that have
these over collateralized under collateralized
positions that owe a lot of money um and and i'm
sort of hearing as well from some of my friends
you know that are doing funding rounds and stuff
vcs aren't as willing to to you know go and uh
fund these things as they once were so i'm sure
that's a bit of an indicator for sentiment uh like
we'll sort of see where things go it's interesting
because um you know we often say that these
um four-year cycles are driven by the bitcoin
halving and so we tend to start predicting things
and based on that on that metric and it's been
proven right um so far however people like willy
woo who also you know look at the on-chain data
um have started to say that because of all
the smart money that's come into the space
um these four-year cycles are now sort of done and
finished um what's your take what's smart money
i guess like um you know like the micro
strategies and like major institutions
institutional money that's the thing if they
were smart they would have been in 12 years ago
so that's that's the thing so people go oh the
smart money i think it's the dumb money right so
it's like that's how i see it is you're the smart
money george you go in 10 years ago yeah well it's
like i'd pick any time frame that's like not today
like that's that's smart money so like yes look
i think institutions coming in has probably been
a thing which has happened this bull cycle which
everyone like probably drove a lot of the hype and
you know everything number go up and everyone's
happy um but it's also a double-edged sword right
because that also means that we're very correlated
to stocks uh which we are it's like literally
the correlation chart is like exactly the same
so that's bad because that means that these
institutions now have crypto on their balance
sheet and then oh the stock market's going down i
need to cover my positions i'll sell some crypto
because i have a small uh you know piece there
and i don't really you know care about it so
i'm going to sell that first and then that
makes crypto you know worse off for it so
i think fundamentally like you need people and
i always say this like the the primary reason to
get into crypto is like the ideological philos
philosophical reasons for it um you know that
that's sort of the most important thing in my mind
and there will be people that come and go there
will be traders that appear on twitter that like
tell you looking at the charts and the stars where
they think the number and the line will go um but
but these are sort of you know passing through
uh you know these people are sort of passing
through so i think the the people that have
often had the best returns have been the ones that
have thought of themselves as investors rather
than traders so i think that's how people should
consider themselves is like you know why why do
you think that this is the future of the financial
world um why do you think it's good for people to
to have bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies um if
if those reasons are sound and that plays out
great and i think it's either going to be like
bitcoin's either going to be zero dollars or a
million dollars um it's still in that anything
in between that is like just an undecided state
um we're and the the longer that we're not zero
the more likely a million is so uh so yeah there
you go how to hear first on the latest show i
love that i love a good prediction um but you
didn't fully answer the question for your cycles
are they over um i assume they must be if all this
institutional money's coming in and it's therefore
not this uncorrelated asset yeah four year cycles
i don't think we need to put a timeline on
it that's what i would say i i think the the
the macro is so messed up in the world right now
like america's how much in debt like on the books
30 trillion or something trillions yeah yeah uh
like unfunded liabilities 300 trillion um like it
brings in like trillions less in tax revenue than
it can to actually go and pay the bills so like
fundamentally the us dollar the linchpin of the
entire economy is screwed like long-term doesn't
matter if it's a bull market spare market you know
the stock market go up or down like fundamentally
you look at it on a long scale doesn't work can
never be paid back debt must be printed in order
to to keep going um so uh so yeah i i think in the
long term like things will will go up the question
is like is that a four year cycle i don't know
i i think things will be much faster now i think
the the leverage in the ecosystem and all of
the money printing that's happened after covert
has just made things like happen way quicker
so you might slosh all one way and then slosh
all the other way so we might be down 80 today
and then we'll be up like 200 percent tomorrow
um like that i think that yeah quicker cycles
is is probably the way to go so probably not
four years um yeah maybe quicker and does that
align with the bitcoin halving and i mean yes
it could be coincidental though i think um and
uh yeah like if you look at the the the coins
which a bitcoin halving like reduces from uh new
supply like it's actually not that much like the
exchanges pick any market on finance and it will
probably do more daily volume than the entire
you know halving bitcoin of like the last
month or so so yeah it's uh it's something tbd
yeah and speaking of um the whole thing is um
speeding up um that 2030 agenda where you'll
owe nothing and be happy i think that's speeding
up to 2025 i think so it's you know it's just a
catalyst and actually i think somebody posted
today an article from forbes from 2016 which
actually shows them talking about this 2030 agenda
we've only just become more aware and awake to it
because of everything that's just happened um so
yeah it's it's it's speeding up that's for sure um
you get to read i know i know exactly that poor
guy as well who's become the face of the great
literally literally that poor guy he probably
all he wanted to do was be a model or something
and then he ended up being becoming a great
reset oh that's funny um he's probably like not
even vaccinated he's probably just like really
adding all this stuff but there you go um but
we were talking about like you know narratives
and adoption and things like that um you know
bitcoin's always whole always held that um that
narrative as um as a hedge against inflation
um and that's sort of the reason why people tend
to flock to um to bitcoin um so what do you think
is going to be that reason i was thinking
it's everything that you mentioned it's
all the rubbish that's gone on you know canada
freezing accounts and all this stuff which will
wake people up what's your take yeah uh so the
question is like what's the catalyst or bitcoin
you know where does it sit in yeah yeah because
like right now um you know we're seeing a 40-year
highs when it comes to inflation bitcoin isn't
really acting as that hedge against inflation in
the short term um so people aren't necessarily
flocking to bitcoin as a hedge right now
um so what would make them flock to bitcoin um in
the near future yeah it's a good question like so
the whole hedge against inflation thing again it
kind of depends on your perspective right like
you could go and look at the chart and you can
say well you know for the monthly we're down
for the yearly like maybe we're down but actually
after two years we're up like 200 and after
four years we're up like yeah 500 or whatever
the number is so i guess you know the whole
hedge against inflation thing like does that mean
that has to always go like one line straight up uh
all the time i don't think anyone expects that
right so it's kind of like what time frame are
you assuming that this is gonna happen and and
what are the reasons that people might want to
to hold crypto i think it's probably getting
closer to people like so for example um a lot of
i've had to do a lot of like international wires
recently and it's most painful hateful purpose
horrendous it's and like money just disappears
and nobody knows why and then it's like oh it'll
bounce back in 30 days uh oh and that's
like a normal acceptable thing apparently
um and there's an intermediary bank involved for
some reason and then you have to pay their money
but you don't really know at the start of the
transaction how bad it is and yeah like you know
just trying to get like bank accounts reactivated
and these sorts of things like the whole system is
just completely terrible um and i've done a few
payments recently where i've just paid people
in tether um and i was tweeting about that
recently as well where it was just so much easier
like what's your address here's my address and
i just paid them done they don't have to think
about anything and like it's everything's provable
like i can give you the the transaction link um so
i think like we're definitely the more broken the
system is it's actually better so i think things
need to get worse before they get better um and
i i'm actually on the one hand yes things getting
worse for people is bad but on the other hand it's
like i think it's actually for the better in the
long run and people will be better off in the long
run if things get worse so you know if the local
banking system doesn't work and everyone switches
to crypto because it doesn't work or the local
currency uh you know gets wrecked in a whole big
blow up somewhere like the 1998 financial crisis
um yeah maybe that's a catalyst for people to to
actually go and switch i think that's probably
looking more and more likely by the day uh it's
just a question of like where is it actually
gonna flare up first and uh yeah i think like
international payments is certainly one area that
should like be displaced by crypto like so easily
yeah i totally agree with you um it's funny that
you mentioned that because i've actually also
been doing a ridiculous amount of international
payments recently and they're disappearing like
i've had a big payment that should have arrived
which hasn't arrived like they're it's actually
insane three to five business days it's been a
month like can we can we get some customer
service um it's actually insane because
obviously i'm british and you know in in the
uk doing payments from one person to another is
super easy um it's free faster payments is fine
um but as i expand and i i move around the world
it's actually horrendous yeah why are you
okay with this like why is there not riots
in the streets i don't know because this should
affect everyone like in some really bad some way
yeah i i don't really know i also think it's
because like you know what it is it's because
we're moving towards a global
world aren't we so like initially
okay tech is developing but we would
we would stay within our own countries
whereas now borders are of course we have
we have portal control but borders are are
dropping the world is getting smaller you know
with all this technology and we're all working
remote and internationally and everybody's
sort of going all over the world um and so i
think as you know tech continues to evolve and
so the world becomes smaller perhaps then it
will shed a light on it and more people will
realize how broken it is what do you think
yeah i mean often i've also found that the best
systems to move money have also been the systems
that have worked for thousands of years so the
the oldest transfer system in the world is called
and it's basically you know a guy who knows a guy
and then money moves and it's like you know you
pay someone and then they pay someone else locally
because the local systems often work okay like the
domestic banking in uk it's fast and whatever but
whenever you need to like convert between these
different systems it's just complete mayhem um
so yeah like i've i've seen a lot of that like in
a previous life in the remittances world i think
the number was that there's there's something like
2 000 individual payment systems in the world
and like that means like wire being one system
uh and then like swift and faster payments and
whatever else and local countries and apps and
all this sort of 2000 different systems so
like that's the fundamental problem of why
things are so broken it's like literally nothing's
interruptable interoperable nothing really works
everyone has their own currencies and their
own agendas and their own rules um so like
really you need like a level playing field right
and that's what i think crypto is and and maybe
that's bitcoin um and that is like the one unit of
account that you can just sort of move everywhere
and it's like really simple to do and if everyone
agrees on that then life becomes way better and
economic growth you know goes very well and people
are able to do much more stuff in the economy like
if you have to spend days trying to pay someone
that's such a waste and i often think like
and then there's people employed to like do these
jobs as well and i i often think like their job is
based on an incompetent system being terrible and
that's that's such a waste of like productivity in
the economy like you have all these people just
earning money for doing like nonsense things
um there was a very good book called [__]
jobs uh which uh everyone should go and read
um but uh yeah it sort of sheds a light a little
bit on some of these things that we take for
granted every day maybe they don't need to exist
uh maybe they can be automated uh and uh yeah you
know payments is a good example of that well
i have two questions that i want to ask you um
the first one is with everything that's going on
in the world right now um you know in terms of um
stock market um wars um supply chain
issues um you know just all this broken
brokenness um do you do you think that it's it's
destruction by design um or do you think we simply
just have incompetent people um in charge yeah
you know there's a good saying don't ascribe uh
negligence to what can be described by
incompetence and i think it's i think it is
uh uh you know incompetence i think it's like it's
not a a plan per se that i would say or you know
if there's like overlords that are moving pieces
on a chessboard you don't believe in the overlords
i mean there are people who want power absolutely
yeah um and you know these are horrible people
um i don't want bill gates putting a microchip
in me um but you know would you like elon musk
uh no i don't want anybody checking sorry to check
yeah even if they long come that was a great idea
um but um yeah look i i so they probably
are like a lot of baddies out there um but
often like how do they impose their will upon
people everywhere it's it's quite difficult
um so like yeah there might be some common threads
there uh but i think there is a lot of dysfunction
in the world and there's a lot of like you know
muppets in high positions and often these muppets
just are prone to making poor decisions we see
this all throughout history there's emperors
and rulers who are just incompetent and are like
total fools and that's how they're remembered for
thousands of years later it's no different
today um so like we we have a lot of those
people around the world right now and uh yeah
i think that's the main problem and i think the
solution to the problem is not trying to like find
better ways to do things it's to make the rulers
and uh and make them less important to your
daily life so if they can't impact your life
that's the ultimate thing like i wish like the
president of a country was such a useless position
they couldn't decide anything for anyone's life
you know they couldn't lock you in your home or
they couldn't you know take take away your money
and your bank account or close it or freeze it or
whatever um i think if i if we had you know more
of more of that of uh you know taking away a lot
of that power and just ascribing by a rule book
um i think the world would be a better place so
um so yeah that that's what i hope we can get to
one day is to reduce the power of these rulers and
maybe the best way to do that is to take the money
away from them via via crypto so i want to push on
that [__] because of what we spoke about earlier
um you know with solend and things like that um
i still feel um and i'd like you to maybe convince
me otherwise i don't know it's up to you um i
still feel um that bitcoin is sort of the only um
or one or not the only like one of the safest bets
just given there is no um just given the
decentralization and and everything that
we saw that happened with solend um you know where
they could actually vote um and if you didn't have
i think you said seven hundred thousand dollars um
you didn't get a vote um so yeah what do you think
uh like bitcoin's been through many different
crises in its history as well um back in 2010
there was i think that was the one where
there was like 184 billion bitcoin bug
and they had satoshi had to roll back the chain so
there was a chain reorg at that point and that was
about one year into bitcoin or was that 2010 yeah
so it would have been about a year and a bit into
bitcoin's history um 2013 uh i think there was
another incident then that was another i think
rollback with a client or something like that i
think it was like the bitcoin core client 0.7 to
0.8 or something like that so again that was like
a majority hash rate decision literally one person
doing that the time was btc guild um and then
i've i've been around where gigahash dot io had
51 hash power for like two weeks so it was through
the goodness of their hearts that they didn't
double spend transactions uh and we're all here
today to talk about how wonderful bitcoin is but
that that's a couple of years into bitcoin's
existence right so okay let's look at these other
chains how old are they usually a couple years
and they have these problems okay so they're on
exactly the same trajectory as bitcoin so where
will they be in 13 years um probably a lot better
situation i would hope um so i would say that look
bitcoin isn't a shining beacon um there have been
problems in the past and we should be real with
that that they are real things that have happened
um and okay given that information like what to do
now like yes bitcoins in a really good situation
right now uh you know there's maybe a couple
of ways you can measure like decentralization
people throw around that word a lot right oh
decentralize this where to centralize that
um i kind of don't like it anymore like it
because it doesn't mean anything like people
don't really know what they what they mean when
they say it um there is one way to to measure
decentralization it's the nakamoto coefficient i
think it's called uh it's a measure of like how
many people need to collude to essentially do
something bad in the network so like basically
you want you want the maximum number of people
necessary so you want the coefficient really high
because that means that it's very unlikely that
tens of thousands are out people around the
world that all don't know each other and all have
competing economic interests are gonna like all
screw each other at the same time to their own
you know detriment um yeah so but there's some
blockchains that you know they might just have one
person who can who can do it so look bitcoin ranks
highly there um celina actually ranks very highly
ethereum ranks very highly there um there is no
on off button for all of these other alt chains
as much as bitcoin maxis would like to tell you
um zlana has 1700 validators um none of them have
the off button uh ethereum has proof of work at
the moment it'll be going to proof of stake soon
see how that goes i guess but proof of work's
been pretty solid for ethereum so far having said
that ethereum came out of a fork we're currently
using forked ethereum if we all cared about
decentralization we'd be using ethereum classic
um because that was pre-dow hack that's why
ethereum forked in the first place because
vitalik didn't like people losing money so again
like all of these different systems uh like they
they have each had crises in in their lifetimes
and um some of them i think now you you can't
just say hey i'm gonna launch a blockchain uh see
you in 10 years when everything's all good it's
like no no you have to speed run the last decade
for these things and try and learn from all these
mistakes and then just like never make a mistake
ever i think that's pretty unrealistic um so yeah
i don't know if i can convince you but i would
just say like you know there lots of things have
happened to lots of chains including bitcoin so we
should just keep an open mind yeah no i appreciate
that i think it's good times conversations um
lots to um continue to learn um so given we are
in this um dreary crypto winter dreary bear market
what would your advice be to people right now
to the dreariness um well yeah how do you
survive a bear market what should they be doing
i think again it goes back to like learning the
fundamentals of things um so this is a good time
to research because often in a a bull market you
get all flashing lights and explosions everywhere
hey this coin's making a billion percent you're
going to get rich tomorrow blah blah blah
that's often what people see uh when you know
bull markets happen and when that's not the case
people maybe find themselves a little bit lost um
but i think like if you think that cryptocurrency
is going to be a force for good like look
into these d5 protocols what's the lender
like can i get a loan by clicking a few buttons
you know with a smart contract and is that better
than a bank why is it better than a bank um is it
easier than a bank um can i go and send money and
move payments overseas without having
to talk to a bunch of muppets between
9 00 a.m and 5 p.m every day um like you know
all these things right so it's i i would say
like that's all you can really do in a bear
mark in a bear market right it's like focus on
the education focus on finding like either good
projects or good people that you like and it's
not really investment advice even if you don't
have any money to invest i think that it's just
interesting like even if you're interested in
freedom um and like what do these people have
to say what's their philosophy why are they doing
things if they're doing things to get rich it's
probably not the not the people to follow um but
yeah if there is some sort of meaning behind it
then great they're they're sort of the people to
to look out for yeah i think that's a really good
last sort of final note um you know be aware
of the narratives around certain projects um
and companies and people um that's really really
important um so george what um where can people
follow you um you know how can they find out
more about step give us the the full overview
yeah uh i'm on twitter at george underscore harrop
uh or step finance on twitter as well just uh just
find us uh we've got a discord as well so yeah
always open to hear from new people actually
you know one thing as well that happens in in uh
in sort of bull markets or bear markets is we're
seeing just a lot of new people who are totally
brand new to crypto they have no prior experience
of any of this kind of stuff so actually a lot of
our customers like maybe even the majority over 50
are in that category they have no prior experience
with other stuff so you know that's that's good
that's um you know there's new people uh
getting interested in what's happening in
this ecosystem and learning and um yeah you know
come and join and we're happy to help educate
amazing guys go follow george um he has um a
lot of incredible commentary particularly on
things that are going on in the world right
now um freedom maxi which i think is super
important um we need more people like that and
yeah definitely go check out step finance um
while you're there george thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure catching up with you
thank you so much for having me it's
been a pleasure absolutely and guys
please don't forget if you are watching
on youtube to hit the subscribe button
hit the like button so you never miss a video
we'll see you all next week malaya high or pancho